greetings everyone i'm really excited to
welcome professor kathleen cruz
gutierrez here today
um especially because her work resonates
with so many of the exciting
conversations
that are going on at yale and elsewhere
at the intersection of
environmental humanities southeast asian
studies
history and of course in my own field of
anthropology where everyone is talking
about the entanglements of plants and
humans
as well as science and technology
studies which dr
gutierrez is deeply involved in she's
working at the forefront of all of these
fields
and using the critical study of the
history of botanical science
to rethink a range of assumptions about
philippines history
ideas of region in southeast asia not to
mention
just region but how southeast asianists
themselves imagine the idea of southeast
asia itself
and the role of science in imperial and
nationalist formations
i think there's a lot of conversations
to to have between
faculty at uc santa cruz where she has
recently taken up a position
as assistant professor and all of us
here at yale
and i hope this conversation today will
be just the first of
many to come i want to say a little bit
about
her recent dissertation in my course on
the politics
of culture in southeast asia we read and
discussed this brilliant piece of work
the region
of imperial strategy and we had a
vibrant discussion and all of us in the
class found it to be
extremely multi-layered and in the
course
i asked students to write book reviews
of the works we read
and i thought it would be appropriate to
quote from one such review
written by orvin mallory who is here
you could see orvin there i didn't know
orvin would be here but a brilliant
undergraduate student who actually is
majoring in a stem
field but interested in the philippines
and southeast asia and
southeast asian studies so i'm just
going to read one paragraph i hope you
don't mind orvin
i've just snatched a paragraph from your
brilliant review
orvin writes in the region of imperial
strategy
kathleen gutierrez asks us to move the
kaleidoscope
through which we have been viewing the
history of the philippines
if only slightly in a way that brings
the unexpectedly rich story of botany
into the political history of the nation
in doing so we pry open an unseen
network of individuals and institutions
ripe with new stories to tell seeing
filipino history
bound through prescott's paradigm the
seemingly
unconscious division of a pre-1898 and
post-1898 philippines
gutierrez seeks to uproot this tyranny
of historiography to portray the role of
scientific collaboration and fostering
the makings
of an inter-imperial hegemony of thought
for gutierrez the philippines is not
merely a peripheral figure in the arena
of european imperialism's decline at the
start of the 20th century
but a central hub of it the seeds of
post-imperial and post-colonial logics
were not planted in the halls of
versailles or the international
botanical congress
but within the letters sent from the
gardens of manila
i think it's such a beautiful evocation
of this rich
tapestry of science and technology
studies southeast asian studies
that we encounter and professor
gutierrez's dissertation
and so i just want to use that as a
window to open us
into today's conversation um today's
discussion will be sort of a talk show
format
and so i want to build from orban's
introduction to the dissertation
there and ask uh professor gutierrez uh
to tell us a little bit more about this
dissertation
the region of imperial strategy um
you describe a series of spanish era and
then american era botanical text
and then you use these to make an
argument about the emergence of a kind
of
botanical science that transforms
philippine history
so i wondered if you could just tell us
a little bit about some of these texts
and some of the actors that you you so
brilliantly
discuss in the dissertation and how you
mobilize
those to get us to think in new ways
about the philippines southeast asia and
other things
sure thank you so much and thanks for
the introduction orphan that was amazing
very generous of you in your disc and
your description of it and i think you
really hit the nail on the head i mean
so much of the the genesis of the
dissertation came from this problem
what's happening around 1898
why is science especially projected in
this way in which
we have sort of the spanish imperial
backwater
and then we have the u.s progressive
period in philippine history
and and i wanted to just investigate it
a little bit more see what was going on
see what was actually salient and then
find where there was something divergent
and it came down to botany and so if you
sort of muddy
1898 as this strict division in
philippine colonial history you actually
see
quite a bit of similarity across the two
botany projects under the spanish and
the u.s
and so by looking at certain texts i was
able to find that one of those things
that muddies 1898 is this preoccupation
with
the region this idea of the philippines
being a part of a floristic region and
so there are spanish botanists who are
invested in that and there were u.s
botanists invested in this as well and
so by way of texts
um one of the texts i look at during the
spanish era
is this 1883 publication um by sebastian
vidal
who's this katalan botanist perhaps the
most
famous secular spanish botanist in the
late 19th century in the philippines
it's illustrated with regino garcia
who's a local illustrator a filipino
local illustrator
and they're really interested in putting
the philippines flora
in conversation with other flora from
um island southeast asia would become
island southeast asia
the same is happening in the u.s period
particularly with the work of elmer d
merrill who's perhaps
the most well-known us colonial botanist
that we have in philippine history
and he's working on regional flora
slowly while he's in the philippines
he's looking at
indochina he's looking at the indian
subcontinent he's looking at ambon and
the dutch east indies
and he's putting the philippines in
conversation with regional flora as well
and so for me
i'm really curious in the dissertation
about what exactly
is connecting this this intellectual
trend
and i argue that in part it's happening
as a result of
kind of how botany is internationalizing
and becoming sort of this neo-imperial
formation
of international collaboration and one
of those strategies is
the region building and flora becomes a
really great determining platform for
this
um in ireland southeast asia but what we
would really again consider the broader
region
um you asked about people eric and so i
divide the dissertation through these
stories of three individuals
garcia who i mentioned is this
illustrator who also is
kind of known as a botanist who learns
it on the job even though he doesn't
have formal training
sebastian vidal the secular spanish
botanist who even though
is really famous in the philippines at
the end of the 19th century
his career gets eclipsed in the
historiography in many ways i think
because there's this focus on u.s
imperial science that clouds
what's happening during the spanish
period
and then my third main actor is mary
strong clemens who is a u.s
plant collector um she collects all
throughout what would become southeast
asia
and so i follow her career a little bit
through the philippines
and by looking at her career i'm able to
open up conversations about local
collectors in the philippines who were
also contributing to botany at the time
and what i love about these people is
that their careers overlap
some of them collaborate with one
another some of them mention each other
in their correspondence
and they really help again sort of muddy
1898 i think when you follow actors
who are just kind of pushing aside a
period of
periodization for a moment in our
narratives and allowing us to see what
other
dynamic configurations are happening
intellectually
at the time
thank you kathleen i have this book
actually
that because when i read your
dissertation i pull i looked in the yale
library
this is the one by vidal isole
plantas de filipinas and it's the one
and i'm also sharing with the group the
names of those people because i have it
in my notes from reading your district
so people can have those names
but if i open this i'm just curious if i
open this and show it to
to the group um i don't know if people
can see
can people see this when i share this um
can can you just say what it's like to
encounter this in the archive and how
opening a book like this reveals
something about philippine history it's
really
i was trying to communicate this with
the students in my class but i hadn't
yet got the book from the library
it took a couple days to get it and i'm
just curious like
when you there's these archival
materials right that are in all these
libraries around the world
um and hidden in them is these kind of
hidden stories i wonder if you could
unpack that a little bit um in the
encounter with one of the plates because
there's something in your dissertation
as well
the way in which you attend to the
drawings and there's like a kind of
almost an
archive inscribed into the drawings
themselves right
i wonder if you could expand on that a
little bit definitely yeah thank you so
much for bringing the text out and
you know i have to admit that part of my
investigation began with vidal
he sort of left behind the best archive
from this period in philippine history
and
it's all in madrid but what i was
starting to discover as i was looking
through vidal's archive was this sort of
peripheral character who would just
emerge this regino garcia who
he collected with who took him around
the philippines
um somehow his his resume right we would
have the resume of the spanish service
appears in madrid which is really
unlikely for a philippine born in
filipino
and so i kind of started following the
breadcrumbs through that and
garcia's name appears right in this
particular text as the lead illustrator
and it was only through following garcia
that i realized that there was this
larger story to be told about this one
locally born individual who starts off
as an artist
who gets hired at the botanical garden
of manila in part because
he needs to help raise his younger
siblings
puts aside his fine arts degree and kind
of goes in and works in the garden
um and becomes really the lead
illustrator for the spanish colonial
project um in the last decades of the
19th century
and so process-wise you know i'm looking
at this text
for much more significance than i think
i've originally gone in
and i was telling eric this that you
know i would spend maybe like 30 minutes
to an hour just looking at a plate
figuring what was so different about it
and unique at the time
and only after maybe consulting with
another art historian was i realizing
that garcia was doing something really
artistically different
with botanical plates compared to his
contemporaries who are producing
synopsis the synopsis genre in other
locations other countries and certainly
other colonial terrain
he's doing things that's allowing him to
deploy his sort of fine arts acumen so
if you look at the plate that you know
eric showed
you know plants are overlapping they're
kind of um
there's a 3d element to it a vibe of
kind of a lushness with the page that's
coming out
it's very different from a linear
organization of plant life or even
insect life that you're seeing in
contemporary publications
and this kind of lack of linearity this
ability to show
plant life almost as a kind of lushness
of the archipelago
i think is speaking to a moment again
where these texts or these images are
communicating
a different kind of philippine flora
that's that's more inviting
i mean i think is also reflective of
garcia's own
knowledge of what's happening in the
environment yeah and thank you so much
orvin for showing that image as well um
thankfully in the archive
i was able to find um you know garcia's
process pics
from you know sketch to the rendered
painting of a similar plant
to the actual image that shows up in the
synopsis
and you can just see how complex these
images are
um racilla mojaras who's a really
well-known historian of the philippines
says that the 1880s
is known as this time in philippine
history when we see the most important
publications
to philippine nationalism come out
including
the noline by jose rizal i actually
think the synopsis is one of those texts
and it's doing this in really incredible
illustrated ways that we can continue to
read as its own archive
thanks for that explanation um there's
two
there's two um discussions in your
dissertation that i think it could be
useful to share
with this group here who hasn't had the
opportunity to read it yet most people
probably
um you talk a little bit about this kind
of
um like the
botany of the friars you might say or a
kind of
and how it's discredited in the global
scientific community that's emerging
around the turn of the century if i'm
not mistaken and it'd be useful if you
could explain some of that and how you
also are rethinking that
a little bit and then also you just
you described this emergent concept of
i'm not sure how it's pronounced i read
it as melisia but it may be just
pronounced malaysia it's
m-a-l-e-s-i-a um as
what i think you call it a floristic
region
um and so i'd love to hear a little bit
about those two
things and then i'll have another
question about the the floristic region
but i see that we already have questions
from from the group so
i have a couple more questions and then
we'll turn to questions from the group
yeah yeah thank you and i see you kirby
hi nice to meet your hand
um you know i to get on to the question
about um
friars and kind of friar intellectual
botanical knowledge right in botanical
production
i think in philippine history um one of
the best studies
um friars who is up to kind of
naturalist work
is francisco manuel blanco we study his
florida filipinas which was
written and published in 1837 sort of up
and down as one of the first texts of
philippine plot name
and this is being done both you know the
social sciences and the sciences as well
i mean we're still really investigating
his work
and i think it's an important text no
doubt but what i find really fascinating
in the archives is at least by the 19th
century
the spanish state is really trying to
separate itself
from the work of the spanish friars and
the work that's being done
by secular officials in spanish state i
kind of call this more of like a
scientific state craft if you will
um other scholars have looked at how
late spanish empire starts to double
down
and really show its intellectual chops
to sort of the new imperial world
this is happening as well in the
philippines with botany and so
at some point there are some great
letters in madrid covering this
um different metropolitan centers are
interested in spat and
that's going on in the philippines
they're asking for
texts that are coming and being produced
on the philippines and some of them ask
for
blancos florida filipinas the spanish
state actually comes in and says
yeah it's good um but that was an
augustinian publication and now look at
the synopsis
check this out and you know this is my
you know hilarious summarizing of it but
i think that's a really important moment
right this
this distinction that's starting to
happen between
sort of friar science and the science of
the secular state
and what it's supposed to be doing for
positioning the spanish empire in a very
different way in
botany than it had been in the first
half of the 19th century
there's much more money going into
botany at the end of the 19th century
than we've really seen
in other parts of the 19th century um
when it comes to malaysia
or malaysia depending on how you
pronounce it um
i think it's a really important
confluoristic region to take note of
because what we're seeing at least in
this time period around the turn of the
century is that botanists are creating
a region of their own that they believe
is prescribed by plant life
really the movement of particular plant
genera across
different domains what they're
acknowledging is that this plant genera
is moving across
multiple terrains so it's no longer just
about philippine flora versus dutch east
indies flora
versus that in the british malaya in
british malaya you're seeing what the
flora is across these domains
and so malaysia as a region starts to
gain a lot of credence and salience
among
these botanists why do i find this
interesting well i'm a child of area
studies
i've been in southeast asian studies
since i was 18. i've loved the field
and and for all of us who are trained in
southeast asian studies we know that the
apogee is really around world war ii
it's a field kind of gains social
scientific prominence
um as a result of world war ii and
eventually cold war politicking
um i'd like to push that you know a
little bit further back and if you look
at the domain of science
specifically botany region making was
happening well before world war
ii i mean again i think a lot of these
botanists are sort of seeing themselves
as
standing outside of politics and
politicking
but when you look at again the sort of
inter-imperial configuration that's
happening at the time they're very much
part of it but they're using sort of
botany as this explanation for why
sort of region-making will make sense
and so malaysia as a place really takes
part in that and it's still considered a
floristic sub-region
of the indo-malayan biogeographic zone
so there are
presently botanists and scientists
within southeast asia who are
contributing
to the flora malaysian catalog and
really still seeing it
as a as a concrete place where we can
map flora
thanks kat um this this is really
fascinating and
uh someday i'd love to ask you much
deeper questions about malaysia but i
wanted to
turn to another part of your
dissertation for sake of time
um let's say somebody comes to you and
they say
botany nationalism i don't i don't see
the connection can you explain it
you have a chapter in your dissertation
where you're talking about the
sampaguita
flower and um i think it would be useful
maybe to tell us a little bit about what
you're doing in that chapter and
remember most people haven't read the
dissertation so
if you can describe what you're doing
there and what is the sambagita flower
and how does this offer a kind of window
into the confluence
of botany nationalism floristic regions
all of these kinds of things that you're
dealing with
sure sure yeah and then for those of you
who have read the dissertation
well overhauling the chapter presently
it's changing a little bit
um but thanks for bringing that up eric
so the sampagita for those of you who
might not know it's the national flower
of the philippines it's kind of the
darling
flower it has a lot of popular
significance in the philippines
um and you sort of see it you know
peddled on the streets of manila
it comes up in a lot of cultural
production presently
both in diaspora and in the philippines
itself
so i'm really curious in that chapter
about really kind of taking the sam
pagita up to task and and
just questioning for a moment that it's
always been in the philippine imaginary
really trying to locate when it emerges
and gains
um kind of that power that political
valence
and i locate that in the late 19th
century
where i sort of start to see and i'm
able to identify
the intersection of intellectual thought
in manila
scientific production and botany and
cultural production
how the that becomes this emblem
for the protonation and so
i argue kind of in the revision of the
chapter that it does so
because of its gendered and gendering
qualities
that get mapped on to the nation itself
for the nation form
the sampagita at the time really becomes
this stand-in for
ideal femininity she is light-skinned
she's fragrant
she's in bloom she's in her prime she's
reproductive
uh historian raquel reyes has looked at
sort of this before and how
gender plays a really important role in
how the mother country of the
philippines gets developed
specifically in illustrator and or
enlightened intellectual thinking
at the end of the 19th century what i
think you can add to that though
um is botany and this flower and i
actually would argue that ideal
femininity
comes by way of by looking at a flower
as well and so there's sort of this
co-constitution
of ideal femininity the idea of the
flower and how this gets repurposed
for creating the archipelago or
archipelagic space
manila and intellectuals at the time are
starting to suggest that this flower is
ubiquitous
it's everywhere in the archipelago you
don't even have to describe it because
you just have to show it to someone and
they'll be able to name it
and they they write on it like this and
they're distinguishing it from like the
peninsula jasmine they're saying that
it's
something very specific it only grows in
the philippines
um botany publications are you know
producing information on the on the
planet but if you actually look at the
literature
many of the observations around the san
fegita are quite localized they're in
manila they're in parts of the visayas
and the central region
and yet it's starting to come into
dominance as sort of this popular emblem
and so i think in the late 19th century
that's when it's really starting to take
hold when
when nationalists are seeing this as a
unique subject or object
to start mapping right um and then
eventually
you know the sample gets uh declared the
national flower in 1934
and we've had it since and so i think
having this history is important
especially when we invest i think in
sort of nationalist projects
that take on plant life um as emblematic
of the nation and i think there's
there's always a history to this and
never really just
an acceptance of the always been you
know for me
thank you this this is so fascinating
this discussion and going through
the way in which even a plant itself
can become a new archive into our
understandings of nationalism and region
um i have a lot of questions but i know
that kirby's had a question up for a
couple of times and i want to make sure
um this is a diet multiple
voices come into our conversation so
i'll hold back on my questions and see
where we go and then
if we run out of questions i'll i'll
bring some back in but kirby
please ask your question and then after
that i see
uh someone named chris pugh also has a
hand up
so we'll start with kirby and after that
we'll turn to cressa
and then anyone else put your hand up
and i'll keep track of the names
hi uh good evening from manila so uh
good morning early morning now in manila
so
uh hi kat kumusta uh i have two
questions okay uh first
uh you did an extensive uh study or
analysis of sebastian vidali
solaire's work uh how unique is his work
compared to an earlier botanist who did
uh the same uh botanical research in
manila in the late 18th century uh
juan de cualiera okay so how unique uh
uh is uh with us work compared to
qualiar and and second
uh you mentioned i forgot his name the
name of the filipino
uh filipino uh partner or
or co-worker of uh vidalia
uh would you think that in the 19th
century there was this tradition of
scientific
scientific apprenticeship where in
uh there are there's a clear
tandem among uh among
uh state scientists or colonial uh
scientists at that time so even the
jesuits the middle observatory
uh had uh some uh uh native
okay uh apprentice who who did the
who did the nitty-gritty of work meaning
they they did the field work they were
sent to the secondary stations
to do to do the field work and same with
the for example the the civil and mining
engineers who did
a geological and mining surveys for
example in luzon so
the likes of antonio garcia del canto uh
enrique abele casarego had the service
of
uh cartographer enrique del monte
although enrique del monte
is a philippine one spaniard i i suppose
so
would you think there uh how would you
assess that idea of scientific
apprenticeship during that
particular period in the 19th century so
thank you
thanks curbs hi
you know i think these are great very
philippine history specific questions so
i'm happy to answer them and you know
i'll try to be as um general as possible
to make them pretty accessible
um on the question on vidal and his
difference with
or um is an interesting figure
i mean he's sort of the naturalist par
excellence and
long history of botany in the
philippines i think the doll is a bit
different from him in the sense that
vidal is really deployed to the
philippines towards a lot more
institutional building
uh cuellar's visit you know to the
philippines his study of flora
and in many ways is also kind of a
commercial expedition
um he doesn't quite get to the point of
institution building right as vidal does
for various circumstances
um and vidal is supported by the spanish
state in i think a different way than
cuellar is
right if you especially think of the
late 19th century
where the spanish state was in terms of
developing
scientific institutions this was really
kind of the realm of the royal society
still
but by the late 19th century you see
vidal not only deployed to the
archipelago himself he's coming with a
team
of foresters of botany trained men from
the peninsula
his brother is in the philippines too
his uncle is in the philippines
and they're all really taking up botany
in a different way i think
that light leads into your next question
about training
i wouldn't call it apprenticeship so
much actually and
i can tell you why in the case of garcia
but training is happening specifically
at the botanical garden of manila
school of agriculture they actually
institute this french nada program
to bring in students from across the
archipelago young men
to study in botany and forestry to then
be deployed back across the archipelago
what's unique about that is we actually
credit the finchanda program
to something of the united states right
this the bringing of young
people from the philippines to the
united states to train to send them back
to the philippines
to take up government posts or teaching
posts
this is happening in the philippines
under spain it's just happening in a
sort of within the colony
and so that training is happening more
men from the peninsula are also coming
in and they're
they're leaving to different parts of
the islands
the reason why i wouldn't use
apprenticeship so much though is because
in the case of garcia
oh gosh i actually don't even think of
him as so much as an apprentice as i
think of him in many ways
as someone who is able to stay
institutionally in place as a person who
was local
who who had um elite standing but also
had
enough connections to kind of stay
within the botany institutions and
outlast
his spanish um contemporaries garcia is
an interesting character because he's
really the longest standing
person working for spanish secular
botany through the end of the 19th
century
i don't really think of that as
apprenticeship and when you see him come
into the botanical garden of manila he's
not trained
and actually spanish records make many
critiques of him for his lack of
training and
there's not a lot of effort i think to
necessarily put him
in training or even send him back to the
peninsula this is something he's
learning on the job
and then i would say in his relationship
with vidal when vidal finally arrives in
the archipelago
i consider them equals actually i
consider that vidal's corpus
really only takes shape really only gets
off the ground because of what garcia is
doing
both illustrating you know his texts but
also helping him go around the
archipelago
and collecting with him along the way
vidal dies in untimely death
in the 19th century and it's actually
garcia who is responsible for collecting
and organizing his plant life that's in
their barium
because he was the most familiar with
what those collecting expeditions had
been
and so i'd love to talk to you a little
bit more about you know what's happening
at the jesuit observatory and even sort
of the use of the term apprenticeship
because i think there's something maybe
different and maybe similar
happening in botany but yeah there might
be something a little bit more divergent
thanks kirby thanks kirby for such a
provocative question and cap for such a
wonderful answer
um next we have a question from cressa
pugh and cressa please if i mispronounce
your name
feel free to correct me yeah it's krisa
thank you so much
um and thank you kathleen for this
really fascinating presentation
um i have a question which is maybe
beyond the scope of your dissertation so
i apologize in advance if it is
um but i'm wondering about um the role
of kind of or how de-coloniality
and or specifically anti-coloniality
appear in your work
um i'm particularly curious about um you
know to what extent have there been
attempts to um kind of unravel
these imperial institutions and that you
speak of
um have there been attempts to make
indigenous claims
to the botanical specimens um that you
reference
i remember a couple years ago when i was
in the singapore
botanical gardens and um there were
these
you know pretty significant efforts to
rename a lot of the specimens from their
you know
botanical latin names to their
indigenous names um and even
replanting native trees um
to replace plants that had been imported
from the colonies and so
and i really saw that as a kind of
decolonial move and so i'm wondering
how um you know declinality and
anti-coloniality even
show up in your work yeah thanks so much
chrisa for that question and it's
it's really coming up much more in how
i'm revising towards the manuscript i
think
these questions are important because as
you know as compelling as sort of this
imperial internationalist narrative is
i'm really curious about what's still
happening locally
what's being obscured perhaps by linnae
and botany but is never actually
destroyed by it
and so my focus on the dissertation is
really looking at that vibrancy of
of botanical vernaculars and by
vernaculars i don't only mean sort of
linguistically how plants were called
outside of latin binomial nomenclature
but vernacular knowledges of plants that
even historians perhaps aren't really
looking at or haven't looked at
yet completely um and so
in a project like mine that's looking at
the turn of the century i'm looking at
for instance
weaving in textile implements
particularly because
uh female weavers as they were mostly
female during this time
really don't kind of emerge in a typical
study of botany in the philippines and
yet
their practices were almost entirely
plant-based i mean these were
plant-based technologies
where they were relying on and not just
dyes but also loom technologies as well
and so how do we then read these
materials for instance as vernacular
knowledge as
plants that are still thriving
if not expanding during this period but
again are somewhat obscured by only an
imperial botany narrative at the time
i think the sampaghita work also is
important in this
especially for thinking about
anti-colonial politics that are
developing
or at least politics of
self-determination that emerged during
this period
um and i'm also looking you know in
terms of nomenclature because that's
what she also brought up
um at how plant varietals uh varietals
of rice
in particular and i've mentioned this i
think when meghan was in a different
talk
about how rice varietals are abundant in
the philippines
and how as we currently know it sort of
the latin name orisa sativa
right for rice um existed in the
philippines botanists were using that
and yet botanists didn't know what to do
with the dozens of
rice varietals that had been present
that had local means
and so for me i'm really curious about
the epistemologies
of plant ordering that were very
divergent from lennae and botany
instead of focusing on for instance
morphological characteristics that
define relationship
how are people in the colony at the time
using things like touch taste um
feel of rice in the mouth after before
cooking
right the stage of a rice plants growth
where it is in its cycle
how do all of those names actually
reveal an um
an incompleteness in lynnae and botany
and that's in that incompleteness of
lennae and botany that i think we find a
way cooler
local history to tell through plant
knowledge so thanks krisa
such fascinating discussions um denise
margaret matthias i believe you have a
question
yes so good afternoon everyone or good
good evening from where i am i'm
from the institute for social ecological
research in bonn germany
um so kat i was just wondering about
when you were doing your archival work
whether there was also a list of
introduced species so i'm quite
interested you know like to
to to map out when did this in
introduced species such as you know
mimosa for example the makahia uh come
to the philippines and
and yeah if you've seen that yeah thank
you
yeah you know i have to credit some of
the work of historical botanists in the
philippines that are doing this
right now that are really tracking the
introduction of particular species
domingo medulla in particular perhaps
the most prolific historical botanist
has been doing this from the early
spanish imperial colonial period
by the late 19th century we do see this
in ledgers
of exchange between the botanical garden
in manila
and other botanical gardens that are
happening that are occurred that are
present for instance in hong kong
um that are in singapore and in the
dutch east indies
it's hard to know though i mean i think
i haven't done enough critical work to
look at the introduction of particular
species but we do know
at the very least at this time that
there is a much more acclimatization
work
in place to try to raise other tropical
species
on the garden grounds and so those
ledgers they're in madrid um denise if
you're ever interested in them i can
even try to dig some up for you to look
through
that might be able to start placing some
of these these plants but i would say
the much earlier
kind of introductory um introduction of
plants you'd have to look maybe at the
work of the mingo medulla
really really excellent stuff but we can
definitely talk offline
great thank you uh michael uh van from
coming in from the west coast as well i
believe
it's good to see you
um uh thank you so much for this great
uh
this great talk
i'm committed to him here gonna admit
that i have not read the dissertation
and i'm also gonna commit instead of
asking a question that like
uh is something i'm obsessed with in my
own research but is there a discourse
on um invasive species
yeah that resonates with nationalism and
um
is is there also as a sub subcorollary
any understanding of magellan exchange
um uh colonialism facilitating
not uh plants that are being
acclimatized but plants
that are invading it and going out of
control oh
yeah great thank you so much michael um
and hi
you know that doesn't appear i can't say
that
in the in the texts that i've worked
with from that time period both that are
being produced
by botanists but then also among
intellectuals who are writing on plant
life they're not really commenting
on invasion they're using that language
of plants that are coming in
um and certainly not sort of tying back
all the way to midfield is not what i've
necessarily found although i will say
that that kind of discourse
has come up in a more contemporary sense
i mean actually tying back to
the sanpagita right i mean the sanpagita
itself
is not necessarily um a native of the
philippines it's not endemic to the
philippines rather it's actually endemic
to
um south asia and so
even in the question of nativeness of
this plant right that sort of gets
thrown into the air in particular with
debates about if another plant should
actually be positioned as the national
plan of the philippines and this has
happened with an orchid from mindanao
but you know this this talk about
invasion versus
versus nativeness as you know michael
can become really dangerous territory
especially is how you know plants can be
positioned in rhetoric that has been
easily
alleged against people right and so i
think even when i sort of think about
more contemporary debates and how i
place that
into turn of the century problems of
invasion although i will look out for it
now
more in my archive i'm trying to be a
little bit more careful too about
how my own work might be positioned for
a kind of nativist rhetoric
versus an invasive rhetoric that that
might actually be undoing
some of my own kind of politics i think
doing this work all together
also happy to talk about this more if i
find some some information for you
michael
thanks and i also want to hear about why
you're interested in invasion too
oh well rats just okay
rats yeah exactly michael has a great
rat guys
yeah yeah absolutely thank you for that
thanks uh i i believe the next question
is from al lim and then after that will
be max finley
hi thank you so much for this i'm in
eric's class so i had a chance to read
um this amazing dissertation um and
specifically i'm thinking about
measurement i'm wondering what are what
is
specific about the techniques of
measurement um that locals or botanists
use and specifically thinking about a
general realism that's in the chapter
three um
the bharatiya notion of kind of
interaction and the phenomena and
collapsing subject objective
object in that sense so i'm just
thinking about how that
for the samagida might be similar or
different to for example the dipterocarp
family and the plates that we see
um in chapter two um so yeah i would
love to hear about that
measurement huh standards of measurement
that's it that's a great question right
yeah and in lynnae and botany there
seems to be
what becomes kind of a vocabulary a
shared vocabulary of measurement right i
mean
these texts are sharing um ways of
describing plants
by size for instance and they're able to
maybe describe them
through latin um and this is something
that's getting shared across
empires and so this becomes a standard
way of understanding how we describe
plants right there is a shared
vocabulary a shared style of measurement
what i think is really cool though and i
think what you're bringing up around
sort of the subject
object and the possibilities for
agential realism
is how that measurement of a plant or
even the scale of a plant can change
depending on the discourse and so if you
look back to chapter three
you think back to the san pagita you
think about measurement and growing
space right and how that growing space
actually enlarges
depending on sort of the imagination um
and then you know i say imagination but
i mean sort of
how intellectuals at the time are both
grounding their imagination in
scientific texts
but also allowing for a national
imagination to really enlarge
the growing expense of the sampagita and
then we have sort of measurement turned
on its head
right we actually are inverting sort of
the lane in the norms of measurement and
plant description
and allowing it to become sort of a lot
allowing the plant to become much more
encompassing
of a wide archipelago and that's a
really exciting part right how does the
sample itself sort of start to push
against
these linear norms and so i really thank
you for bringing that up and
something that i probably should
incorporate more of the revision thanks
now
max finley i think you have a question
yes thank you and thank you very much
professor gutierrez cat
for that presentation i really want to
read your dissertation now i want to
read the book even more
so the first question i guess the first
question is when is the book going to
come out
and the second question is um
and forgive me if i go on a little bit
with this one i'm very curious
i think following up on questioners two
and four um chris and michael
about from a different perspective
though about this internationalizing
botany
and this creation of floral zones and
i'm very curious in particular
how much of the philippines who are that
the botanists in both periods who are
imagining these zones are creating these
zones how much the philippines are they
accessing is there a geographic bias
in the kind of flowers they're putting
forward for example i um
just because i happened to have it on my
desk i was not thinking of the german
travelers in the courtiera the
translations by william henry scott and
he has a few people there but are they
part contributing to this international
dialogue at all or for that matter
are certain geographies such as ifugao
the cordiera or mindanao being excluded
and
to borrow a michael's language being
turned almost into invasive species
within it even though they are very much
endemic
or very much part are parts of the
philippines being included versus
excluded
i guess that's the broad question oh
that's great yeah thanks max
fun fact for everyone i met max in the
ust archives the university of san
back in 2018 so it's just great to see
you here again it's been a long time
um when's the book coming out i have my
history colleagues some of them here in
the
call uh give me some time
i'm just gonna get there hashtag coven
but it'll be there
um uh and keep an eye out for it
in terms of internationalizing botany uh
that i could talk a lot a little bit
more about
and geographic bias i actually think
geographic bias is happening on
different scales
um in the dissertation and how we look
at this history right
even if botany is internationalizing at
the time the biggest mover and shakers
movers and shakers of botany are all
sort of imperial metropolitan centers
and so the notion of the international
is really only kind of
uh geographically limited to to europe
at the time and this sort of extends to
the united states at some point but it's
pretty limited i think when we're
thinking about philippine flora as well
the geographic bias is mostly luzon
um and certainly manila these are very
well studied locations for botany
up until sort of the early 20th century
there are other investigations that are
happening i mean there's this extension
penetration of mindanao um that starts
around the mid 19th century as well
and it's flora is getting sort of
considered in this colonial
catalogue that's building but i would
even argue that again
much of this colonial catalog is really
sort of
situated in the the colonial capital
radiates
outward and then only kind of decades
later is it incorporating other zones
and so you ask you know about guardian
peoples or
peoples in mindanao and whether the
plant life there is sort of getting
considered right or if it's being
considered invasive or if there's a
particular rhetoric
i actually think during this late
spanish colonial period not enough is
really
known but what is known are the is the
commercial potential
of these locations particularly the
timber that's coming out
and that makes it become a much more
lucrative place for investigation
but i would say in terms of taxonomic
botany absolutely
there is still kind of this this
geographic
bias up through kind of the earliest
decades of the u.s colonial period
and then that has to again lead into
questions about well what are we
considering as part of regional botany
as it's developing at the time
what's being constituted as
participating in this creation of the
regional zone
and how are those limitations being
expressed and that guys you know ties
back into al's question
where does measurement then become a
little bit more elastic
um geographical space become much more
elastic
to meet these intellectual ends
thanks um next question is from orvin
hello hello doctor um so
i was really inspired by chris's point
um earlier as was a lot of people in the
rest of the comments and
i think a lot of my questions have
actually been answered but i'm thinking
like just in terms of the dissertation
itself
um right like that sort of narrative
that you build with the three
sort of like protagonists is i think
really really interesting it's a really
interesting way to kind of break through
that that
um that kind of like the kind of
blinders that we have called 1898 and
just kind of
create a more nuanced like take on
um that period in philippine history and
but throughout i was kind of wondering
like of the presence of
kind of india and right like
like um like india like
yeah like native as you say like um
kind of actors and players i mean
obviously like
you know garcia is like you know phillip
it's like kind of like a penny so a lot
all right not a penis solar the opposite
of that
ah shoot what is that
you know it's still that's still like
within like as
as you said like the colonial metropole
um
and even through like the later chapters
has
within like the building uh like the
construction of the sampagita is this
national symbol it's like a
it's a very illustrator sort of move
right like
it you know and the these kind of these
kinds of
these kind of like anti-colonial or
decolonial projects
as you know it's kind of like a common
theme throughout southeast asian studies
has a really uncomfortable relationship
with
like really uncomfortable alliance with
nationalism and so
kind of wondering like it
is the is this dissertation just like
the lack of indian voices in this this
is this dissertation sort of just like a
like a makes it kind of like a victim of
the archive of sorts because
right like um obviously like
a lot of these letters are written to
and from like you know colonial centers
to spain and stuff like that um
and secondly um looking forward into
like the like in to the conclusion of
your book i
was reading some really interesting um
kind of application like implications
um of this sort of international botany
and sort of like um nationalistic or
imperialistic science however you want
to call it
um that uh for example like
i think you cited one of your works
called imal de marcos toad lilly
i i think that's just the greatest title
i've seen
in a work of academia um
but i was wondering like right like what
can we look forward to
in the future in terms of or at least
future as in like beyond 1945
in terms of what botany played and like
the robotnik played in the philippines
yeah oh what a cool question thanks
orvin
um and i love that point about um sort
of southeast asian cities uncomfortable
because kind of uncomfortable alliance
with nationalism it's what we study
you know i mean tell me a southeast
asian who hasn't asked this question
or like written about it somewhere for a
class you know or at some point in their
own
you know personal body of work um
you're right you're absolutely right i
mean these these characters these people
had archives to leave and even then
though i mean
we have to kind of go back to garcia his
was much much slimmer
than mary clemens or sebastian vidal i
mean we have his visual archive
that i think is the most robust but even
then i mean and that's slim you know
lucky by chance resume you know to find
you know the spanish archive
but there's not much there in part
because of the destruction
that you know manila libraries have
faced at multiple instances in the last
130 years um
at the same time i think when you bring
up around india voices or more local
voices of different actors you're right
problem is the archive and what's that's
prevalent um whose
you know information or letters are
preserved and even then there are
problems around that in terms of what
we're seeing is text
and who was um able to access text and
linguistic production at the time
and the other was um really around
botany and really what who was writing
botany
botany was in spanish and english
primarily if we're thinking about
institutional
rene and botany had i had more time with
the dissertation
um and this is really the objective for
um the manuscript is to become a little
bit more methodologically creative
going about these sources and i got to
this a little bit with chris's question
um how am i looking at different source
materials than for newer archives to
bring out
other individuals who were carrying
plant knowledge at the time
um finding voice can sometimes be a
lofty endeavor
um i think you know giving voice to
particular
actors you know is is one that requires
a lot of ethical responsibility
that i don't take lightly but when i
think of for instance weavers at the
time
who were certainly carrying plant
knowledge i'm pushing myself
to look at these different sources
non-textual sources
for trying to map out what that plant
knowledge may have been
another group of actors would definitely
be collectors plant collectors
local guides these were by and large
people that were hired in situ
to assist colonial botanists and
foresters with collecting or with
surveying
um local guides and collectors sort of
appear in the dissertation as you're
probably familiar with maximo ramos
who becomes the main collector for the
us colonial outfit alongside other other
men
who are working for the bureau of
science again and their archives are
really disparate i mean they're found
sort of just mentioned in passing on
places like jstor plants
through clemens archive from some of
merrell's archive as well
and so even piecing together their
stories what their life may have been
the different kinds of knowledges they
brought into the institutions
as people from you know a particular
location in the colony people who
had decades of collecting experience
those are the kind of actors i really
want to bring out in the manuscript
i don't want to lose sight of garcia i
still think that he's a really important
figure to bring out and i think you also
bring up an important point
he's also still kind of more of an
illustrado insular figure
that becomes important um even in sort
of the story of botany in the
philippines and so i
definitely don't want to lose him but i
hope that sort of answers some of your
questions for how i might start to think
a little bit more about mining different
archives for botanical knowledge
where the colonial archive is very
insufficient
post 1945 super interesting time
really cool stuff going on um i've
started collecting some oral histories
with
botanists who trained or conducted
research during the cold war
and what i love and i'll just kind of
give you a snippet here when i've asked
you know how did the cold war
impact your research by and large they
say
it didn't and so i thought to myself
like okay i'm going to begin the next
book by saying the cold war didn't
happen for philippine botanists
and really dive into what exactly where
these comments are coming from because
certainly botany was exploding
in the post-war period it was really in
ramping up even under marcos
and so the way that i want to attend to
this next project
is looking at how plants and their the
scientists who study them are kind of
also partaking in sort of this political
project of new philippine independence
in some way
and what i also think is really exciting
is is kind of taking on the notion of
agentual realism or
uh plant agency in all of us too so how
do we start to think about plants
as sort of being historical actors
alongside these plant scientists
um and i think that that's it's a kind
of a fun exercise to start to imagine
and i don't mean to say that i'm arguing
that plants necessarily have
sentient decision-making powers
over the actors you know that i'm
looking at in this time period
but i'm wanting to really push us to
think much more about
plant growing patterns plant movement
across the archipelago
as you know people at uc santa cruz are
really fond to do is to start
thinking with plants start writing with
plants
to allow for a very different kind of
history to come out especially
the cold war period in the philippines
as you know orville that's really been
dominated by a particular set of
literature that's focused on marcos
i think that's focused really well on
domestic and transnational protests
but hasn't maybe done enough yet to look
at its science and what science is doing
and i know
kirby on the call is doing that too so
i'm really excited about the post 1945
work
thanks for all these stimulating
questions and answers um we're
at about one o'clock typically
i tell everyone at this time that i'm
going to keep the the session open
for another 15 minutes or so but i i
also give permission to those who need
to leave at one o'clock
to do so gracefully um and i just want
to thank everyone for being with us
until now
but we will continue we have a few more
questions after
about 1 15 or so i'll turn off the
recording and then we can have an open
chit chat session
as well so stick around if you have the
time but you're also free to go if you
need to
um so we have a question from tree funk
tree
uh hello uh dr uh professor gutierrez
um thank you for a wonderfully
stimulating
conversation that we've been having uh
my question is very brief um
i wonder if you could speak to or speak
on uh or share with us
how you happened upon or discovered
intimately
botany is a heuristic and
also a modality for unpacking and
studying
filipino history culture and society
that's all yeah thanks tree good to see
you
um you know yeah i can answer this a few
different ways i mean i think in terms
of my own professional intellectual
trajectory
um before i entered into academia i was
in public health um for many years
and i thought that when i entered into
my doctoral program for those of you who
are maybe still in the starting stages
of figuring out your phd project
i thought i was going to work on
colonial public health a good way to
begin in that
is through medical botany which becomes
a really important facet of philippine
public
health um i worked with laura nader who
is also an anthropologist he's worked
with eric
a little bit and he really encouraged me
to look at philippine medicinal plants
um that really took me back to to my dad
actually because i had known somewhere
down the line he had written on
medicinal plants in the philippines and
so
i thought you know what let me let me
just ask my dad about the avocado
you know like it's materia medical
quality
uh and that just got started some pretty
amazing conversations and
discoveries for me and sort of the gaps
in literature about the history of
botany in the philippines
the lineage of botanists is very very
narrow you can really track
who learned from whom especially over
the course of the 20th century and as i
started to sort of envision my dad
in that lineage and he certainly is in
that lineage
i started to become interested in sort
of tacking back further back to find
kind of debates within botany the gossip
you know it bought me the the really
amazing stories that revealed parts of
philippine history
otherwise um maybe obscured or not as
clearly seen
through something like botany um in the
past and so
it's a very personal i think and also
intellectual trajectory of mine
um and i and i'm really always you know
proud of saying
that that much of my work or like love
letters to my dad
for scientists who i think has been
pretty peripheral in many ways
even in his sort of experience in
diaspora in the united states and so
i think that's kind of my short long
answer to
to why botany now but i think it's still
opening up greater investigations again
of other plant sciences
and other ways of thinking about the
environment that are feeling very
natural
to the progression of this trajectory
[Music]
thanks for that um harry go ahead and
ask your question
thank you for uh thank you professor jrs
for being so generous and thoughtful
um in your exchange of us today actually
my
my question you touched on a little bit
in in your thinking
of over and around places historical
actors but
i was i was wanting to ask a little bit
about perspective
because it strikes me that when when we
look at plants
we kind of can see we kind of we kind of
glean
alternative or new or different
perspectives on cartography
on questions of nation heard on on
regionality and on history
you know looking at plants
teaches us to look at malaysia and see
and see the kind of relationships that
that
that um that create different grounds to
like think your history
but also kind of i i've been thinking
about how plants
you know looking at plants teaches us to
look at history from the ground up
in this kind of like working like a
methodological kind of incisions on like
a
visuality that's like um from below
um but then that that led me to think a
little bit about
perspective and thinking about plants
not just as objects of study but as
subjects of studying what's the auto
to study with um
you know plant knowledge being not
something that that botanist bear but
that
you know it being the the knowledge that
plants there like plant knowledge being
like plant epistemology
so i guess i guess my question and i'm
struggling to know exactly where to go
this and maybe it's just a property to
speak a bit more about france's
historical actors
but i'm also wondering about whether
thinking relationally with plants or
thinking through plants as
subjects of knowledge can lead to a kind
of like
maybe kind of like um unsettling of like
the visual as this kind of like um
mode of kind of like rational domination
and like transparent like understanding
of history
and like you know what is your
perspective on the idea of
of the perspective that you know of the
kind of like um
ways that ways that plants can
intervene and interact and produce
history themselves
yes oh so cool yeah no thank you harry i
think that that's
yeah i can share a little bit of some
ideas that i've been sort of teasing
through
to answer this question for myself i
think it's a very fun one
um and and i can share and just say too
that the kind of idea of ground up
visuality
and perspective and methodology is so
great um i never thought of it like that
i never thought of it like that and i
think that's you know important for
for work for how we might start to just
again undo maybe a little bit more of
the human
human centered approach even in a field
like history right which i think other
subfields of history have done a
marvelous job and sort of undoing right
um when we're thinking about plant
agency you know i i go about this
you know in one particular way with the
imelda marcos toad lily and it's
again an exercise in just suspending for
a moment the idea that humans had
control of the entire situation
in the discovery naming and promotion of
this imelda marcos toad lily
which had been discovered in the 1970s
and named after her
in particular i'm curious about how this
one lily
which is actually only grown known to
grow around taiwan
and southern china somehow manages to
end up at the southern tip of the
philippine archipelago nowhere seeing
anywhere else in the archipelago but is
somehow
in this location found among um the
purported cave dwellers the tasaday
people if you're familiar with
philippian
anthropological history the thessady
were purported to be cave dwelling
people that were discovered suddenly by
the marcos regime
um this lily was discovered among them
and it was named after imelda marcos to
kind of uphold the marcos's legacy
in supporting indigenous peoples um
we find out later in history of course
that the president were a huge hoax
we would discover of course that the
marcuses were plundering boxes
themselves
but i question for a moment and i wonder
that this one plan that's able to jump
somehow from taiwan all the way to the
edge of the philippines
in a very very remote location somehow
participated in the hoax as well
i mean it becomes subsumed in this kind
of laughing stuff that the marcos has
become
after they're pushed out of office in
the 19 in 1985
and i like to think about that i mean
how can we think of a plant
who's simply working outside of its
growing range is also contributing to
this
and that's where i think plant agency
sort of intervenes a little bit more
when we think a little bit about how you
know we can create
how plants are sort of actively creating
communities of people themselves right
ontologically speaking
communities of botanists can't exist
without plans
right how do those constitutions then
change over time
how was a particular moment like the
cold war philippians
being constituted in science not only
because of political social intellectual
forces
but because of the plants that are
presented are
presenting themselves to botanists too
and i think that's a shift in
perspective that allows for a very
different kind of storytelling
but that allows again for a little bit
of a de-centered approach
to the human actor hope that answers
your question harry
such a fascinating conversation um i'll
turn it to tui for the last
question and then um after that we'll
turn to our informal conversation and
i'll stop the recording after the reply
to that go ahead tweet
okay thank you professor hamm and
thank you professor i'm not sure i can
pronounce your name
correctly which i okay
so in vietnamese i'm not the philippines
in filipinos
and i'm not in them like science uh
environmentalist or something but
i have such a long time working in the
farmer union so i go
very closely with farmers and
i see your research i wish i read your
research station but i
i didn't have change when they am
waiting for the book
um i have a question about like when i
work with the farmers
and i am interested in development like
i care about development so when i work
with the farmers
i talk a lot with the farmers in the
medcone delta a lot of them complain
about like a lot of
like the protein like that's a very
interesting reason you
you there isn't about like
a night in history or early 20th century
not not at the present not about
development
um but uh when i talk with the farmers
they come in about a lot of
fish kind of fish disappear
and a lot of plants even grass and
plants
we don't see anymore in in the fields
and i also grow up in the in the village
so
my family my parents are farmers so my
entire
time would work in in in
in the gardens so but about like 20
years
now i don't see a lot of plants
like because of the like the
developments people don't work in the
farms
no in any agriculture so they don't have
water farmers to walk in like to pick
the grass like i did
before so they use a lot of chemicals in
the mekong delta or in my village in
in the southeast of vietnam so
do you have like certainty like
development affect a lot of
affect the potential like a lot of blood
and even my my
in my in my garden now my mom have to
grow
a glass let's have a spray and see
growth that's why we
we have a lot of grass before and when i
came here
i went to the the the park i see a lot
of grass
that i saw before and i don't know and i
don't see it now in vietnam
i only see it in the botanical garden
when i went in the mecca when i went to
the botanical right
i see a lot of them i saw a lot of in
the botanical garden that the
farmers complained to me that they don't
see it anymore
so like do you have any plan that you do
research on like the effect of
development on both potenti in
in the philippines or in southeast asia
i think vietnam have had that too so
that's just my question about your
future plans
because i don't have knowledge about
your best
expertise and i don't haven't read your
your work okay that's my question
yeah thank you tweet i appreciate the
question
um i'm not sure if megan is still on the
call too but i mean
i actually think that you know
even if i work in history i absolutely
you know find myself responsible to
being responsive to contemporary
conditions
that might very well impact you know the
environments of southeast asia
i only ask if megan's on the call
because i'm making a plug
for the center for southeast asian
coastal interactions
which brings together different
disciplines including history
anthropology and the life sciences to
attend to these bigger questions that
are really confronting southeast asia
today
much of the focus right now of the
center has been on
coastal life for instance mangroves um
and man growth degradation but then also
mangrove
um rejuvenation and ability to to
regenerate
in spite of climatological changes that
are impacting southeast asia in ways
that
i don't even have to explain because i
think we're pretty well aware even on
this call about what we're confronting
right now in the region
i think in terms of a historical lens
that i know i'm really excited to try to
offer and to continue to build is
is the question of disappearance and for
whom disappearance becomes important
and so even when we think of
deforestation that's happening at the
turn of the century
the actors that are you know writing
perhaps the most on deforestation
are colonizing foresters who become
pretty
involved in why timber trees for
instance are disappearing at such a fast
rate
and become much more invested in
policing forests in order to prevent
for instance locals from from taking
down trees that aren't ready to be felt
and so these questions of development
really tie into
well whose one disappearance is being
valued
at you know the expense of what kind of
development that's happening at the time
and then of course this excavation i
think is orvin and others are really
trying
to really insist on the different kinds
of perspectives
in relationship to that disappearance
sometimes it's harder to find an archive
but i think is still
all the more irrelevant and you must
maybe look for instance at different
kinds of sources i think this is where
songs poetry particular kinds of
folklore that we might be able to track
back to this time period become
important
because then we're able to see what that
discourse might be on the fast vanishing
force
that become really the preoccupation of
colonial botany
at the turn of the century so i hope
that answers your questions we
we should definitely try to see you at
some seacoast meetings
that are still online and hopefully you
can bring your vietnam perspective too
well thank you uh professor gutierrez
for such a fascinating and generous and
wide-ranging conversation
and for sticking with us for so long and
entertaining all of our
expansive questions it's really been
quite fascinating
so first i want to just have everyone
join me in thanking you
for such a fantastic talk and give you a
round of applause